tout le monde a en mémoire ces images
les faits s'étaient produits le 5
janvier 2019 lors d'une manifestation
autorisée des gilet jaune de bellechasse
à paris un chariot élévateur avait forcé
le portail du secrétariat d'état de
benjamin griveaux l'ancien porte parole
du gouvernement avait dû être exfiltré
ils ont également des fonds c'est la
grise ont cassé deux voitures et
quelques vitres et anne on a mis en
sécurité lancement des personnels qui
étaient présents inacceptable
inadmissible moi ce que j'espère c'est
que les vidéos internes permettront
d'identifier ceux qui ont été
responsables qui seront conduits devant
la justice et sévèrement condamné cinq
personnes ont été traduites en justice
pour ces faits le procès a été renvoyé
plusieurs fois deux ans de procédure qui
ont éprouvé thomas hess l'un des accusés
il simplement brièvement monté sur le
chariot élévateur avant le choc
ce 5 janvier il essayait de fuir une
charge des forces de l'ordre on remonte
sur la route bellechasse et on va sort
un fenwick
je vois des gens klaxonnent et du bon je
vais faire pareil je vais on va rigoler
un peu et je monte dessus j'achète mon
gilet jaune et conducteur qui arrivait
la démarrer je suis dit bon ça régale
avec l'effet de foule
elle clame haut ce qu'on est et je suis
monté dessus comme un enfant
qui monte sur un manège quoi et je
descends et d'un coup je vois il fait
une marche arrière et paf dedans une
personne sa famille c'est un ministère
jusqu'à on l'a pris sur les réseaux
sociaux la pression sur les médias
thomas n'a pas conduit ni abîmer de bien
mais il a pourtant est inculpé de vol du
chariot et de dégradations de l'hôtel
particulier ainsi que de deux agences
bancaires n'avaient rien fait quoi un
pan est à côté de films et c'était comme
un enfant ce qui concerne pas la casse
moi je suis là pour manifester chez manu
tu vas pas manifester c'est voilà je
manifeste
je crie dans la rue mais je suis pas là
pour casser des choses et en fait nous
on veut juste défendre notre bifteck à
la fin du mois on fait juste défendre
notre nos droits
le délibéré est tombé ce 27 novembre
deux prévenus sont relaxé de toutes les
charges
deux autres dont le conducteur sont
condamnés à 18 mois de prison dont une
partie avec sursis et l'autre
aménageable thomas a écopé de 8 mois
avec sursis et doit payer de très lourd
dédommagement
les avocats des deux prévenus relaxés
satisfait dénoncent quant à eux
l'acharnement du parquet à poursuivre
leurs clients elle le savait et nous en
avions la preuve depuis le début elle
n'avait rien fait de plus que de filmer
les poursuites du parquet de paris et
est de ce point de vue là tout à fait
scandaleuse
il répondait à une pression de
l'exécutif pour pour au final pour
suivre le maximum de personnes qui
étaient présents le jour de la
dégradation de la part du ministère
dès le début concernant mon client le
dossier était clairement de ces deux
relaxes
sauf que le parquet voulait absolument
poursuivre plusieurs personnes ils ont
poursuivi ce qu'ils ont trouvé ce qu'ils
étaient sur place sans faire de
distinction entre les agissements de
chacun en faisant une poursuite globale
et politique au moment où ils ont été
placés en garde à vue et poursuivre en
comparution immédiate on était encore en
plein dans le mouvement des gilet jaune
avec encore des manifestations tous les
week-ends et une répression
des manifestations extrêmement forte
donc par la police mais en réalité sur
les instructions du parquet sur les
instructions notamment du parquet de
paris thomas hess compte faire appel
deux ans de procédure n'auront pas suffi
pour juger cette affaire de chariots
élévateurs vu par certains comme un
procès baudruche
sachant que les auteurs de dégradations
dans les locaux du secrétariat d'état à
eux courent toujours